speaking
chris thank you i'm trying to do this
meeting chris
members and officers during each item on
the agenda please put your hand up
you will wish to speak i will then
invite you at the appropriate time
invited to speak please remove your mask
put on your visor turn on your
microphone and speak clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
and ensure your microphones remain off
when not speaking
members there are officers attending
remotely azaria
the external auditor georgina button
damian geller and hannah wheatley are
all
attending remotely
apologies to them and we've got
apologies for absences from councillors
jarvis and councilman and pastor swain
is here this evening substitution casper
9. thank you
item 3 on the agenda
i'm sorry yeah one two three on the
agenda the minutes of the last meeting
on the 29th of july 2021
on pages 5 to 10 of your
um
[Music]
members do you wish to agree by saying
[Music]
of interest to disclose the existence
and nature of any disposable peculiar
interest other
interests on non-pecuniary interest into
items of business on the agenda having
regards to
six to eight of the code of conduct
members
members are reminded that they are also
to disclose any interest as soon as they
become aware should the need to rise
throughout the meeting do i have any
no okay
item
file on the agenda public participation
i can
advise that we have received no
submissions members of the public
item 6 on the agenda an update of the
audit of accounts to consider
the update report director of resources
i will ask mr leslie to present
his
accounts
council statements
could you
please
be quiet
[Music]
um
very quietly i am talking very quietly
you mr leslie
uh the preparation of the accounts this
year has been significantly impacted
directly and indirectly by the ongoing
pandemic much more so than last year
requirements have been introduced and
starting changes
in the middle of the closure
from a resourcing perspective
staff have been sick with code and
resources have been focused on the
tops which takes away capacity
with closure for example in the
residence areas where they are
processing business grants and release
despite all challenges the council's
draft accounts were published before the
deployment of the 30th of june although
actuals of council's audit working
papers were not well prepared as planned
the pandemic has also compounded the
national issues of auditor resourcing
the audit of the essential fund is now
expected to commence into october and
the council's audit is reliant on this
work completed before our accounts can
be signed
as the accounts will not be audited by
the 30th of september the council is
required to put a notice on the website
explaining reasons for this no
significant issues have been identified
by the
auditors the finance team is again now
fully resourced with person stuff in
accordance with the structure and has
experience of this year's closure
and the intention is to bring the
audited accounts to the next committee
meeting on the 18th of november
thank you mr leslie do i have any
questions mr leslie
thank you um
i just wanted
leslie you said that the draft accounts
have been published are they published
on the website
yes absolutely um they're on the website
uh to the public oh okay because i
didn't have a look earlier i couldn't
see them maybe i was not looking in the
right place yeah yeah
um
did that take
4.7 uh you mentioned that the orders
will
uh the accounts will be ready for
approval at the next committee meeting
although they're on the public domain
before that
that's right so produce a draft set of
accounts
that's right
um
from our side the auditors are obviously
trying to get the resources in to
the
queries and take care of the outstanding
queries
at the moment what we
is the essex pension fund or
that's due to start in october but if
that is delayed further then that will
have an impact on our account because we
can't sign our accounts off until that
has been audited
do i have any other
just a little bit questions
that uh because of the delay by
essex county council that this authority
is having to face costs
i think you're so intimated that that's
going to be the case
extra costs for us and delay um if there
are extra costs i think it will be
for other reasons rather than the delay
basics
pension fund
thank you
so are there any other questions for mr
leslie
[Music]
the recommendation is to consider this
report
can i have a seconder for that
recommendation
councillor fleming thank you
can members agree this by ascent
yeah
thank you
item seven on the agenda is the review
of the
corporate performance call to one i will
ask miss
hughes to now present to members
the
agenda item thank you
by council in february of 2021
the report covers quarter one which is
april to june 2021
this means that corporate performance
measures have been updated now
of the report
so far the three themes are broadly on
track although we are accepting that the
impact of kovid will still be in within
performance reporting throughout the
year
section three
four highlights uh the indicators that
are at risk for quarter one
in the place thematic strategy we have
one at risk which is the five year
housing land supply updated and
published
prosperity thematic strategy doesn't
have any annotated at risk and community
thematic strategy doesn't have any
annotated at risk
section three five highlights areas
where data is pending that are new due
to refreshing priorities and where has
the baseline data available
members are invited to review the
information set out and confirm
assurance that corporate performance is
being managed
effectively thank you
thank you uh
the recommendations are the one that the
members review the information set out
in this report and appendix one but the
priority focus gives the strategic
outcome level performance
agenda
sorry a little bit
but members confirm that they're assured
through this review that the corporate
performance is being effectively
vanished do i have a seconder for that
thank you councillor flynn
has there any questions for
miss heroes
counselor
thank
you i have
a number of hundred questions uh the
first one is on page 25
and this speaks about doing the housing
the district needs
uh it talks about the the calls the
sites
can you answer that question
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much
it talks about
awaiting data
um
i find it very difficult to gain
assurance from this report if we are
awaiting data do we know what data it is
who's going to give it and when are we
going to get it
can you help me with that please
so for example the cost for fly tip
clearance and we're just getting
information about the cost per clearance
so you can put that information in there
but where there are new measures it's in
just a little while to populate that
data
obviously once we've got it we'll be
able to see how that changes over time
okay thank you i'll move on now to page
36
this is talking about the percentage of
businesses engaged in
class
and again another baseline
no starting point
this is on page 36.
if you can georgina
so
okay thank you and finally
uh
42
uh it talks about community performance
measures and your data um it's always
about that the number of schools
supported by the ndc year six transition
to identify children with address mental
health concerns
um
um
can i ask what is this district council
doing what is their role in supporting
these unaddressed mental health concerns
what is the council's role please
do dream
shhh
thank you very much for that for that
reply but
uh i'm not sure it's answered my
question what is it that ndc does
to support the schools
to identify these children that we can
address mental health
so
back to councillor heard's um request
about the site i think i saw that it was
advertised on the mdc website and don't
quote me on this but i think the 23rd of
june
was it was the deadline so we should
actually have if we're in september now
there should be some data available for
you on
uh how many sites were
provided um and then thank you through
you i just wanted to um
[Music]
um
engagement with businesses i was hoping
for a sort of definition of engagement
is that
just they're on the mailing list and
they receive the newsletter or is it
something a bit more
in-depth than that thank you
i'll let you come back very quickly with
a supplementary then i'll go to
councillor hull and then council stevens
so so in the light of that published
stunt uh the 23rd of june uh if we have
met the target in quarter one
uh
i asked what the
um
what the thoughts are about meeting the
target in quarter two
please
[Music]
before the reason why it hasn't been on
track is because the action plan has got
too many variables to be able to
guarantee that we'll be able to get back
on track
and so that's why it's flagging at the
moment
i don't know
do you want to send out something to
this committee
um once you've done some
i've said so much you've looked into do
you want to send an email to all the
committee to answer that question
[Music]
um
being told if they don't get the
flight if they moved within a certain
time then they get legal action taken
against them um
as you know you know
especially this time of year and
especially in
for
andy
thank you okay
council stevens
um
but absolutely we can move that into the
actual
that information that's no problem
council edward
yes thank you can i just clarify please
um going back to
try to
indicators at risk
which is
the favio housing land supply
which is at risk
on under place systematic strategy
going on to here i
[Music]
moment the call for sites it's what
could come forward for the new ldp
but that's now closed
it was confirmed
[Music]
we
yes it would
so
so
so
thank you
thank you
thank you
okay is there any other questions
council sign
thank you
yes
i have several
comments on this item
but as far as the
new science is concerned for the adv i
think we can't
the value of tourism to the district
and i would be interested to know what
method is used to actually work that out
and on the question of um
intergenerational projects one is
there
is there any other project
being considered
so we get the data back from
the intergenerational projects
is specified i believe in the thematic
strategy
more detail once
yes
page 25 where
you've got two items it's earning a five
year housing loan supply and the first
one says that on track
that seems to me a contradiction um and
in the commentary on it
um it says
action is in place
um if that's anything else alone
with the ndp covered in the first point
um i would be very interested to know
what that is
but the phraseology there that the
immediate action
is implies that it's our fault
that we're in this particular
and so the supportive outcomes
district needs
so the particular one that's at risk is
just the five year housing landscape
statement updated and published
so the other elements that make up the
housing district needs the action the
other action plans they're all on track
at the moment they're all delivering as
expected
and so it's not necessarily a
contradiction that um
there's a number of different actions
that make up how we go
for that particular area
then
does that make sense
what is turning up through
the chair and what is the questions are
we planning ourselves to take to remedy
this five years
but
uh yes um
it it mentions what gives the impression
that there are things that we are doing
as a council to deal with the five-year
history
other than what we're doing in relation
to the idp
i was wondering what what those actions
are what is this actual man from
that mr
is
um is there
also
i don't know about any others that have
been identified
yeah thank you i i understand that but
perhaps
and lastly on page 33
there's mention now that um
business is not just that businesses are
dissatisfied with the services of the
council and
what
can you be more specific on that one
in terms of
specific services that they engage with
but we ask a number of questions around
um do you feel you're getting enough
support from molden district council
and how do you feel you're getting value
for money from molded district council
and so that's what
sort of informs that measure
businesses
thank you so much
we only had 28 businesses respond
and so obviously we don't get thought we
didn't have a lot of feedback we will be
really running the survey again this
october so we're hoping to generate a
bit more feedback this time
and but yeah
we don't have more detail because
obviously the low response rate okay
well i've got a counselor stevens that's
been sitting there waiting but she's
happy for you to go well just very
briefly
how will we be advertising the survey i
don't think it's enough just to put it
on the website how else can we do that
as well in terms of response rate so we
will be looking at
thank you
so
can we put that on there to say where
these targets come from yep
any
through the studio
managed effectively
should that be monitored
um i suppose in doing quarterly reports
and the commentary and obviously the
overall um
scores and directions that we're giving
performance
and this is all around and
to what extent we're actually addressing
women performance
so you know the action plans the
information in there does actually show
you where we're addressing poor
performance or what we're doing to try
and get performance back on track so
yes
okay
[Laughter]
we have the two recommendations before
us they have been seconded aren't happy
to accept these by saying
you agree
thank you
i to mate on the agenda is the review of
corporate
quarter one miss hughes can you present
the report please
yes so the risk report presented to the
committee covers the quarter one of the
corporate register which is april june
2021
all risks remain unchanged in school
since the last report received by this
committee
however there are three risks that have
been highlighted where we expect that to
be changed next quarter
and this was at the request of the
committee last time around having a view
on what might
and support the growing population
and there are likely to be changes to
this as the emerging picture from the
pandemic polls
r29 failure to deliver services as a
river of coping 19
and we're expecting changes from that as
restrictions ease
and spar 9 failure to have a coordinated
approach for inward investment
maximizing business rates growth
members are asked to review
this register
and confirm
through this update that corporate risk
is being monitored effectively
thank you miss years
recommendations are little one that
members review the corporate risk
register
and provide comment and feedback for
consideration
literally that members are assured
through the review that the corporate
risk is being managed effectively
little three that members challenge risk
where the committee feels that the
council's corporate goals may not be
achieved can i have a second for that
thank you
councillor fleming is there any
questions for miss hughes
councillor swain yes
thank you chad
um
treated
i don't agree with it
because it's really nothing to do with
the council and
it's not something we are responsible
for so
we can't fail to do it
it's uh basically
and we should be
business engagement
and business sports and encouraging that
don't know
skills et cetera so i think we have a
key role to play in the
community around um supporting jobs and
encouraging growth
we're approaching that from i think
obviously being impacted by um this time
which had a huge impact which is one of
the areas where we're seeing uh risks
thank you mr leslie uh
have you got a comeback because the
council has got his hand up
and
well
yes i mean i think there is
a general um
employment areas is equivalent to
creating jobs it obviously isn't but
there is a role for the council
promoting the area promoting
um the area to businesses and
that is
something we can do and in any case the
failure would be failure to develop a
program for
promoting uh investments in the um
new incomeness of the district
thank you mr swan it's supposed to put
your hand up thank you
rate um was
uh compared with now
a lot of our strategy was based on
increasing
uh
and expectations of increasing our
revenue
by increasing the non-domestic rate
within the district
um what in fact has
a major
player like quests leaving
done to the strategy
[Music]
they've been given to businesses locally
which
has uh will have an impact in supporting
capsule tax base so we may see some
things that come forward
what i do have to to have some of the
collection rates i think that's probably
another important consideration around
businesses is inflection
so we take for example august um
and we look at pre-panic levels we're at
50 about 55 collection rates in august
uh currently this year it's about
about 98.5 collection
but last year during the pandemic only
93 percent collection so yes there has
been some significant impacts and built
reduced collection rates uh and reduced
space into our budgets and the mtss
has been taken into account their
projections and we continue to monitor
that as we build um next budget as well
thank you leslie
this is
and but
what i'm looking for is to see whether
we
how much of a decrease and non-domestic
rates we are suffering from firms that
have to still move down to the district
the sort of uh decline in perhaps
businesses that may be noted through um
the overall collection uh rate so yes we
do have have the baseline unfortunately
i don't have those figures to hand
be happy to circulate perhaps
those figures to the committee can see
the actual top level reduction in the
baseline if you could do that then
um councillor fleming you had your hand
up in council hall
and
um
about our 29 failure to deliver services
as a result of code 19 it's in red
um
so the quarter one services continue to
be delivered challenges that exist um
i just wanted to raise
at this point um
in a district with an elderly population
you can't access services digitally
so
i just wanted an update on plans to have
a fully manned reception desk for those
residents that can't
access our services any other way thank
you
georgina
okay
[Music]
come on
sweetly
thank you
is that okay that's the plenty
okay
you had a question
well it's a response
again
david wilson homes near us had an
industrial area and we had a business
that was keen to expand
um they went to look at this site after
being recommended but they said that
they made it difficult
and yet they
were interested
around
and they found that
somewhere in sunderland made
their business so much better to go up
there and move the business out the air
and because they felt that mold and
district council while giving them the
right
opportunities in the area we have
especially with the daily homes seem to
want to
charge so
and saying that's one of the reasons you
know not supporting the local community
getting jobs really okay thank you
uh mr leslie maybe you can
look into that
answer how could
questions
use the internet and
their first thought is i'll just go in
and ask somebody so i do just want to
put that sort of
make that note that it is
i'm sad to see that nothing
excuse me that looks changed on that
rating and it's not even listed at the
top as well that will improve soon
and we could be in serious trouble here
if something went wrong
um
hmm
so
thank you
council stevens
thank you for that so can you advise us
when we'll see this disappearing of the
risk register please thank you
counselor heard you had a question
i think uh cancer students has asked the
very question that i was going to
um
it's really just a question of whether
the risk rating
would reduce because of that
um
but i think that's been very well
explained uh
from us together and the other thing i
just wanted to add uh which is about
uh
it's almost advertising really but
there is a senior safety and celebration
event
specifically for the over 65s which is
going to be held at malden stadium
in park drive
and this will
be looking at
engaging talks and exhibitions showing
the range of information and services
that are available in chelsea
and this is a public information event
paid for by the council so i think
that's good work
thank you very much
thank you mr geller is there any other
questions
i want to refer to part 5 on page 50
um which
um
but rather than that i
think
the
connection to the 8012
possibly more important
than the smrr
and
it should be
another risk
failure to um
to
secure
an improved
access to the 12 junction 21.
and that should be something that
lucy worked on
i think that's more important than the
smrrs
did you want to come back to clarify any
point there
thank you chad i just wanted to um
say that councillor swain makes an
excellent
thank you
any questions
uh counselor
comment and come back
it was on the national radio today about
how well essex were doing and towards
domestic violence and other counties
should take a lead from them
how well they do
recommendations in front of you
you have the through recommendations
they have
um second did
do you wish to take those by a second
thank you
item nine on the agenda is the balance
school card expectations report page i
found on pages 53-55
miss hughes can you present that report
yes so this is the second reporting of
the six monthly scorecard section report
the report builds turner on our
performance
and gives the operational exceptions
and to add as a layer to the corporate
outcomes that report to this committee
quarterly
internally the extended
team review a monthly performance
dashboard
this covers reporting around financial
operational customer organizational
and statutory performance indicators
a full copy of this is available on the
membership sharepoint this report aims
to draw the member attention to the
exceptions where as a council we are
either seeing under performance or
performance that surpasses targets
in section 3.5 of the covering report
the areas of underprivileged are
highlighted along with their associated
management response and action
there are six areas for this report
they are the percentage of business
rates collected the diversity of council
tax collected
reverse and ben's outstanding cases and
process online
commercial income delivery
leisure participation and updating
and misspinned increase
the first five of these were highlighted
in the operational exceptions that came
to this committee in january of 2021
that bin's issue has emerged since then
many other authorities are also impacted
by a national htv driver shortage and
this is something we are working closely
with contractor
overall all indicators have been
affected in some way by the changes of
the pandemic and wider economic issues
but the reporting allows us to track the
extent of the impact and account for
this in our strategies and our response
in section 3.6 of the covering report
the area over performance are
highlighted
they are
channel shift and website feedback
these two indicators were highlighted in
the previous report and noted the work
that has taken place and continues
around digital improvements
and that helps to deliver this but also
this is likely to have been impacted by
the general customer move to online
transactions in the pandemic
members did give feedback specific areas
that could be improved online at last
committee
and together detailed information to
help us with this work
have recently shared a form that members
can complete as they identify further
work and feedback from their customers
members are asked to review and comment
on this report and be assured through
the reporting the operational
performance is being managed effectively
thank you
thank you mrs
that you have two recommendations
recommendation one that the committee
review and comment on it the on
exceptions to service reporting
i did in this report
and little too that members confirm they
are assured for the review operation
performance is being managed effectively
can i have a second
thank you mr boyce council voice sorry
council of boys do you have a question
um
increases
um
i saw today
that
the county council had its case against
the provider of the
refugees um
um
has that created an additional problem
for our
um
waste collection
by additional mileage
um
that
are required
and if if that is the case
this has impacted on
the the uh some of the
misconceptions
do you want to
basically
um faster than
uh no longer processes and
uh waste because of dispute and i think
they've gone into administration
um
is that impacting on our waste service
by having our
vehicle the vehicles that
operate in our district having to go
further
extra mileage which reduces the time
that they're actually within our
district
did you want to say
so
hmm
[Applause]
thank you
uh castle heard you had your hand up
my question uh the only thing that i
wanted to
add what's in the in the action it says
working with the contractor against
about this speeds increase in june
uh working with the contractor to
discuss issues clear communications to
residents to update on these
so
that doesn't really help the residents
who haven't had
those
is collected um but
the thing that i wanted to make was that
this was in june
2021 here we are now in uh
september um
given the operational
absences of drivers
is this something that we could have
avoided
or changed
did you get that mr
okay thank you very much
thank you councillor stephen do you have
your hand up and then we'll come to you
councillor
thank you
um being reviewed closely through the
member working group um i'm on that
working group
since june
so i just wondered whether
there were plans for
another meeting
thank you
yes
to take place with regards to the
numbers
the
summer period is obviously actually
quite a period and and these
restrictions
to the language has just come out so in
terms of comparative data there's not a
lot
there at the moment the places has
arrived
where they will have some real accurate
data and be able to give um
some more projections and have a little
feel of actually how it's all tracking
the swimming
is really almost back to pre-pandemic
levels that's been very successful um
where wherever it is around achieving
membership
and obviously that tends to be naturally
lower in the summer months anyway which
is one of those
thank you any other questions
this one
thank you very much
just on that comment
um
i wouldn't be too optimistic about
the membership
oh my god um
that
there could be shortcomings in in their
management as well which has led to it
um
missing case that
a whole team had to
be suspended because the
person who had a
first aid qualification was off now that
that is a management issue
and there may be other instances so i
think we
we should be prepared to quiz
on what they're doing to try and counter
their problems
and on the
question of that over achievement
i noticed most of them were concerned
with 19
and i think this
comes back from this point which has
been made previously i think
particularly
stevens and this drive to have
everything online
can go too far
and there does need to be
face-to-face contact
particularly in this
area of the
reception
in the offices
thank you
thank you before i go to mr leslie um
we've had a member of the public uh
contact us to say that councillor
morrison are actually picking up
feedback from your phone on the youtube
so just to say that they are picking up
feedback
please mr lesler
in terms of the uh
driver shortage uh
there's been a pandemic that workers
have obviously worked through on that
time there's also been
delays and we talked about absolutely
first aid training so it's been one of
the impacts of first day training hasn't
been able to
during the pandemic time and they are
now catching up uh on some of those
courses they also have to do for legal
requirements
and now the team's obviously faced with
a driver shortage uh and of course the
pandemic brexit uh
taxes um around that so they haven't
been taking action um to do this
it's been a national issue um
staff but as you can imagine agency
staff are innovative at the moment with
the same demands and competition where
we're having around there uh looked at
some of the drivers uh around there for
perhaps the
food based on the seven
vehicles which has slightly different um
requirements um as well so looking at
actually how
some of the driving requirements uh on
that as well and also in particular
discussions around
recruitment and retention how we can
manage
thank you
is there any other questions
no so we have the recommendations they
have been seconded are you happy to take
those bias
thank you
item 10 on the agenda is the annual
government's government statement
actions update i call on uh miss hughes
to represent the report
thank you so the annual governance
statement identifies our action plan to
build on and improve our best practice
around governance at morgan district
council
this is the second time that this report
is presented six monthly to the
committee so that you can see progress
on that
and what we are doing to improve our
governance
as well as any barriers to achieving
this
section 3.4 presents a table of the
actions and the commentary explains the
progress work that is taking place on
these
members are invited to review the
information
and provide any challenge they might
have thank you
thank you
uh recommendation is to review the
annual government statement table and
updates below and challenge when
necessary can i have a second after that
thank you councillor fleming do i have
any questions for miss years
are you all happy to accept
this by sentiment
[Music]
[Music]
call on miss sweetly to present the
report
so
mhm
yes
thank you
recommendations are little one to note
the accident and incidence statistics
and little two to note the work
undertaken during quarter two on health
and safety activities
do i have a stephander for that thank
you councillor fleming do i have any
questions to the officers councillor
stevens
thank you chair i'd like to ask about
one of these accidents where a member of
the parks team cuts an electricity cable
was that the cable to an electric mower
or some other electric cable that was
sort of lying around
okay thank you so um i mean normally in
that situation an electric cable would
be
well made very visible
um
because it would be
because obviously
most staff aren't in the offices thank
you thank you
[Music]
at
other sort of
departments it's literally just the
parks and assets
is there any other questions
know if everybody is happy
then you've had the recommendations they
have been seconded are you happy to
agree that's why i said thank you
item
12 on the agenda is any other business
that the chairman decides are urgent i
have none item 13 is pleasure of the
meeting members thank you for your
contribution this afternoon of this
evening i have to draw the meeting to a
close at
9
50.
um
sorry 8 15.
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to bring to any further
discussion on this forum and please to
leave the meeting properly thank you